the Joe Rogan experience I just watched
the movie about the free free free
climbing movie that's playing on the
plane but the guy that climbed you Alex
Honnold
yeah yeah he's been on here I'm sure yes
he has Wow
I know it's like to focus on something
that I mean how many people have he the
only person that had done that is he or
the fastest who have done it or I think
he's the only person who did it without
ropes yeah yeah - so does to see
somebody that decides like I said
earlier we're gonna make tents I want to
make tents I want to climb that yeah you
get to meet so many people like that
yeah that must be fun well it's it's
very important for me as a person who's
trying to figure people out is to be
able to see this insane spectrum of
exceptional people right to see someone
like Alex Honnold who's a really
fascinating guy yeah very fascinating
guy because he's really smart he's
really tuned in he's really mellow he's
got hands like sausage right yeah this
might look like like champagne his hands
have evolved or something I mean not
these [ __ ] the surfaces of these
insane rocks yeah dude he was telling us
a story in the podcast of one time he
was halfway up the side of this [ __ ]
mountain he realized he didn't bring his
chalk with him so he found some other
climbers that were on their way up that
were on ropes and he said hey do you
think I can borrow some chalk and they
gave this guy goes yeah I have an extra
bag here take it
so he's [ __ ] thousand feet up just
hang it on finding other people were
connected to the ropes and they give him
a batteries over and he leaves it at the
top of the mountain cuz he passes that
up cuz he's not using any ropes
you're a [ __ ] christ man video was
climbing with Alex recently it's like
about March well I heard about fall down
or something he came very close to the
system don't show me a freaking word
don't show me all freaked out got down
to that Wow oh my god that's terrible
that's not good whoo holy [ __ ]
dude [ __ ] all that look I know it so I
jumped out of an airplane with Jared
Leto once did you really yeah with Jared
Leto well it was we went to Paris
California together with a group of
people and I had always said I am never
going to jump out of an airplane that
was always my thing I said my whole life
I'm never gonna jump out of an airplane
I'm gonna go parachute in if you're done
parachuting know exactly I was I feel
the same way but I still ended up doing
it because we drove out there together a
group of people and I realized on the
drive that I was the only person that
wasn't jumping out of the airplane oh
Jesus and for whatever reason my
competitive spirit got the best of me I
said there's no way I'm gonna be the one
that didn't jump out of the airplane on
the way back so we suited up and I just
done that movie Charlie's Angels okay
and there was a lot of parachuting in it
and the stunt coordinators from that
movie we're taking the cast out to jump
out if they wanted to so I went and
Jared Leto was there and you know my
friends were there and and I did it I
did it and I didn't regret it but I'll
never do it again it was amazing it was
exciting it was tandem you know you have
a guy you're strapped on to a guy guys
on your back right guys on your yeah
he's on your back he's on your back he's
on your back there you go and that the
way the craziest thing is you go and you
flip you flip and then immediately you
see the plane the plane is filling your
peripheral vision and then immediately
the plane goes from broke
get small oh man you realize wow that
perfectly good airplane as they say that
perfectly good airplane is getting a lot
further away and then you're and now in
the weirdest part about it was this was
20 years ago now but or 18 or whatever
but you're now you're doing this right
and you kind of realize hey I've got
some sort of control because there's
another guy over there he's like kind of
far away and all of a sudden like you
lean into it and you're you fly up to
him
Superman right now you're this far away
this far away he's got video camera on
his head I don't know what the tape is
and you're looking at each other and
it's amazing and exciting and then the
thing that was weird about it is then
you pull the chute or the guy on your
back pulls the chute and now you're
hanging from ropes your chutes open and
you'd think that would be the time where
it's you can relax but to me the one
time I've done it talking about
parachuting like I know about it the one
time I've done it 18 years ago that's
the scariest moment because now you're
sort of realizing that the only thing
preventing you and you're looking at
your feet now you're looking at your
feet hanging below you and you're
feeling these ropes you're holding and
so I'm holding the ropes going these
ropes give like nothing nothing between
me and it was it's amazing experience
huge adrenaline rush we'll never do it
again because our now at least I can say
I have done it right even though I
didn't ever want to have to be able to
say that now that I have said it there's
no reason to do it again but you know
who knows maybe I will end up doing it
you should jump on an airplane you
should jump out of here I can't believe
you haven't actually I'm surprised you
haven't I think you got a contact high
son yeah I think you should do it I
think you would I think you would dig it
if I lived yeah
yeah you would seems fun you got with
one of those I'm not into thrills like
that like you get your adrenaline from a
strange way to get a thrill I'm not
trying to knock anybody does it but it's
a strange way to get a thrill let's
pretend we're doing isn't it pretty
yeah I get it I get it but I don't I
don't think I need that in my life no
you don't that's what I always said - I
don't necessary they ended up being you
know whenever you're gonna get in a
situation where you end up going out to
a parachuting thing with a bunch of
people unless you know you're you know
in a relationship and the person is
going and you go with them because
they're going and then all of a sudden
you're there and you're going like I'm
not gonna be the chicken [ __ ] yeah you
got to do what you got to do save face
yeah almost died yeah save face people
do die you know what's [ __ ] up about
it is that's one of those things that
you kind of you do it and you think oh
I'm gonna be okay and then one time
maybe you're not and that's all it takes
one of I think it was was it red bands
dad his friend worked with a lady
was it a lady that was really in the sky
diving and she was always trying to get
him to do it and then one day he showed
up at work and she wasn't at her desk
and he said what happened oh yeah yeah
died skydiving [ __ ] yeah all that [ __ ]
all that dude yeah it's kind of yeah
it's like could have anticipated that
you know yeah it's enough enough enough
[Laughter]
[Applause]